well today is hardcore cuddling very
relatively speaking it's still 64 shades
of grey for those of you looking for the
sequel and remember the secret is always
better than the original thing this is
the fifty shades darker and darker and
send pictures back from Mariner 9 a
reed-muller code was used and Irving
Reid is a very famous coding theorist
and this worked incredibly well they
were ever so pleased about the results
they got from this the nice thing about
it from the theory point of view is that
if you want to go all mathematical and
say it's a multivariable polynomial R
you know you can do that because it is
but I can disguise that for you with
read Amana and I can say look everyone
trust me it's just an exercise in
recursion that we're all familiar with
and you've got to be prepared to do
concatenation and bitstrings
which I think in North America and
Canada is called bit fiddling but here
in the UK we call it bit twiddling but
twiddling fiddling we don't mind which
recursion and bit twiddling is all we
need to understand how those pictures
were sent but because it's a recursive
procedure it takes us almost a lot of a
magical mystery tour of everything we've
ever done about codes because if you
build up to something usable in terms of
lots of error Corrections you meet lots
of other almost familiar friends on the
way the N K D notation is what we're
going to use this comes from a previous
video where we qualitatively took a look
at features from Mars and how they were
sent but of course we're now getting
down to hardcore details involving
recursion and bit twiddling but just for
revision the total number of bits in
what you're sending including payload
bits message bits and the parity check
this at then within that how many bits
are devoted to the message itself okay
watch your distance the bigger that
number is the more errors you can
correct
so the correctable errors is your
distance
year minus 1/2 and take the floor of the
thing that we are headed for at the end
of our recursion is 32 bits total 6 bits
of message 16 is a distance this magic
Cove when we've got there will actually
correct up to 7 wrong bits in 32 and I
mean some of them so why couldn't you do
this earlier and the answer is it's a
trade-off the trade-off is we've only
got 6 payload bits whereas where things
like Hamming codes it would have been
more like 26 you pay your money you make
your choice ok well how do we do this
recursion then how does it develop every
recursion has to have a sort of bottom
point where it finishes you know
factorial 0 is 1 that sort of thing well
here we're going to develop the known in
some textbooks is the H sub n codes and
the reason for that is that they are
actually derived from things called hand
Amada matrices there's lots of ways of
getting at these reed-muller codes but
the fact that there is a Hadamard matrix
method of getting at it is in good news
for us because what it means is you can
do it recursively and as computer
scientists were all totally and
completely happy with recursion I know
we are the zeros one of these codes the
very simplest is just so simple it's
laughable just the single big one but
every good recursion has got to have an
algorithm from how you get from this one
to the previous one to the next one and
so on the rule for constructing shall we
call it HN as every stage you take two
to the power n minus 1 zeros and 2 to
the power n minus 1 ones so now where'd
you get a bunch of zeros a bunch of ones
join together by concatenation plus at
every stage of the recursion you
to twofold repetitions of previous
patterns from the previous version of
the recursion it's one of these things
where it's actually start doing it and
they'll keep cross referring here and
you'll get the hang a serious one that's
god-given you can't contest that that's
the bottom okay then so what about 8:1
well what this is saying is that for h1
our n value is 1 so we're going to have
to put it in a pattern here that is 2 to
the power n minus 1 zeroes well 10 is 1
that's to the power 1 minus 1 to 2 power
but anything to power 0 is 1 so you
start off with 1 0 & 1 1 okay but the
rule says and as well as that you're
working set this is called a your basis
set of things you're building up your
working set must also include a two-fold
repetition of the things you had
previously well the only thing I had
previously was a 1 so what's a two-fold
repetition of all 1 1 1
it's all to do with concatenation we're
not at the moment do any arithmetic or
exclusive ORS I mean we're just joining
bit pans together so we are in spawn 1
now rule here which is a quite general
thing in developing these codes is you
can always introduce a 0 vector as it's
called if I keep calling these things
vectors don't worry it's a very inner
phrase you can band it around in the pub
but all it really means is bit strings
you can always introduce a 0 vector of
order n what that means is absolutely
for free and from nowhere I can add to
this 0 0 ok and if I was working with
bit strings as a will eventually there
are four bits long I can just bring in 4
zeros it's bound to be there the zero
vector at whatever length is always part
of your set of colors that's fine so you
can look at this now say you know you
almost got a valid code I don't know in
two bits look you've got 0 1
one one and you say that that's lutely
for free I can have zero zero do you
know if you just added one zero in
they'd have a complete set of 4-bit
possibilities wouldn't you yes and here
is a lovely way to introduce you to what
our glove on about from sometime it's
called a linear code it means if you add
these things together
with exclusive or they'll deliver
something else in the same family well
look there's only one thing we're
missing in this family of 4-bit
possibilities so if I do 0-1 and I'll
indicate my exclusive all binary dish
will not carry with a plus what happens
if you add 0 1 2 1 1 well 1 and 0 is 1
because they differ 1 on 1 is 0 because
they're the same ah that has delivered
me my final possibility of 1 0 so what
we're saying is at every level of this
recursion you take what's called your
basis vectors that come from this
recursive algorithm lots of zeroes lots
of ones plus double ups and what you had
last time you do all of those but then
you add together what you've got in all
possible combinations and you know that
they're form a closed family you'll get
to a stage where they won't deliver
anything different they just rattle
around within themselves now look at
this fabulous code Shan it's so familiar
to us in there but it's not very
exciting because in n K D terms what are
we saying that this is it's got a
two-bit code but the payload is two bits
long there is no space for any error
correction and if there's no space for
any error correction whatsoever then
they must be distance one apart they all
differ by one bit as you go from 0 54 I
have to confess to being completely lost
at this moment I understood what you
said but I don't see how it has a
bearing on where we go it will in next
time round believe me this will have
such a bearing as you can't imagine what
I'm saying is in the trivial case this
doesn't give us an error correcting code
at all so it's useless but we recur one
more time I might need your healthier h2
Oh crumbs you need to to the N minus 1 0
s and 2 T and minus ones that's also the
new thing introduced every time yeah
it's to the power 1 which is 2 so you
need 2 zeros and 2 ones plus 2 fold
repetitions now I did derive that but
that wasn't part of the basis set to
fold repetitions and what you had last
time
well can 0 1 0 1 and 1 1 1 1
don't worry about the zeros you can
always add those in at this stage if we
want to add in a for 0 0 vector we can
do so whatever stage we want is that so
that's just like a you can have the code
if nothing yes yeah it's a bit like you
know when you're doing arithmetic
systems you find zeros are useful but it
really is like saying 5 plus 0 is 5 all
right
but of course with exclusive or it's
handy to have it because if you
accidentally exclusive or something with
itself because they're identical can
yield a bunch of zeros for you so it's a
handicap out there in as a kind of check
that it didn't just arise from outer
space it could have arisen from adding
two things together for absolutely
identical these are what's called basis
vectors for the vector space and
therefore bits long but from these you
can generate all of the four bit
possibilities you're after by simply
adding either taken them as they come or
adding them together with exclusive or
and I'll show this now on this sheet
which are carefully introduced over here
I've introduced a four bit zero vector
which sometimes is called bold zero that
is the zero vector or whatever length
you need remember the x one we got two
more two ones 5 X 2 not 1 no 1 X 3 1 1 1
1 those are the 3 we started with now
add them together in all possible
combinations until you don't get
anything new and I mean exclusive oh of
course X 1 plus X 2 0 1 1 0 X 1 plus X 3
1 1 0 0 how about X 2 plus X 3 1 0 1 0
and finally the final possible come in
nation is all through and of course you
know it doesn't matter what order you do
these exclusive ORS in X 1 plus X 2 plus
X 3 is the same as X a graphic form does
X do you do all that one you get
thousand on one now when you look here
look one two three four five six seven
eight you've generated eight
possibilities out of all the sixteen
possibilities in four bits what I'm
saying to you is you take any two of
those now and add them together again
you won't get anything new
if I take one zero one zero one one zero
zero doing exclusive on those I'll get
zero one one zero there it is look just
above try it with any of though anyone
getting you the other thing I'd point
out to you here is what is the minimum
distance of this code well look a naught
naught 1 1 how distances are from 4 0 2
yeah
the only exception is if you take the 0
vector with the vector that's all ones
you will get a much bigger distance you
get 4 but you're not worried about the
maximum one you're worried about them
anyone want so this thing then it's not
exactly award-winning but it's a step on
the way we've now got something let me
use my crib sheet and write down for you
h2 is a 4 3 2 code and you look at that
and say well that's a bit better than
last time where we learn it any
recursion but we all know from previous
videos if the things only got a distance
of 2 you can't correct an error you can
only detect it and when you look back at
these set of possible colors is how
we've seen that it's actually carrying a
3 bit payload with one parity check bit
at the end of it and overall it's always
even parity yes but we're on our way
we can now fast forward and say what
about h3 what we're going to develop
from here is basically a set of 16 8-bit
possibilities and if you sort of say
well this is h3
what is its nkd rating it's an 8
or for code we're coming on we're
getting a bit of error correction at
last now in this recursive build up our
way 4-1 Shawn 3 3 over 3 1 don't need to
ran down it can correct one error it's
getting up to Hamming code standards
this is we're up to 8 4 4 at this h3
code but probably the most equivalent
coming code I could pluck out for you is
7 4 3 perfect illustration of trade-off
look that will only correct one error
but it's got a payload of 4 bits that's
got a payload of 4 bits and this is
pretty comparable how hard you have to
go with this before you get well we've
done h3 advocate to h5 and we will draw
a veil over h4 completely I will leave
you to read the handout and work out the
basis vectors do it all for yourself or
if you can't be bothered to you can use
my log program which has got an option
into generator let me just say h4 has a
nkd rating of 16 5 8 and that's very
nice look at that 8 minus 1 7 7 half
three and a half round it down it
corrects 3 errors in a 16-bit payload
this is looking good but those clever
engineers at JPL and elsewhere said well
if we went one stage further we could do
even better
h5 this is our target 32 6 16 notice
what's happening is that at every stage
of these Hadamard reed-muller codes the
size the length of them it's exponential
is doubling it's gone 2 4 8 16 32
therefore 64 so they are expanding at a
heck of a rate and as some sardonic
person as one said in the comments on it
that's really extending these codes is
it only gives the cosmic rays more
chance to damage them and that's quite
true so this is a fabulous compromise as
you can see now
I hope you've all by now seen the
previous video with the pictures from
Mars if not you can always go and
consult it but this was just about
perfect to get a six bit payload packed
inside 32 and with a lot of hard work at
the Jet Propulsion Laboratory
you can deterministically decode every
one of these vectors to get its shade of
grey out of it so long as it's not being
hit by more than seven errors you might
have a big decoding effort to do this
quickly enough cuz it can very easily
mount up but that's sort of the problem
for you
mission accomplished really I think this
is a it solves all our error correcting
desires for this particular level of
technology that happened in the Mariner
9 it was always counted a great success
of course things have moved on from
there a lot since that date we've used
secured a shell to bridge across to
something I'm more familiar with open
SUSE Linux and I think I can't remember
in the previous